[Musique]
les mots sont tous dans ta tête pour
te réveiller le matin et sortir de tes rêves
entre mec
tu accumules ces pertes juste dans
ton esprit
si tu le sens dans ton
et chante fort
oh tu sais que tu es
[Musique  ]
c'est à propos de toi tu dois juste
[Musique]
arriver à demain
non c'est à propos de toi Joey c'est à propos de toi
obtenir cette
[Musique] à
propos de toi Joey les bains utilisent
[Musique]
comme si tu n'aurais jamais
ton cœur dans la machine à laver ouais au
printemps
il est  Charlie German, elle ne peut pas faire une
pause,
mais parfois croire, c'est déjà
si
tu sais que tu
chantes
fort, tout tourne autour de toi, tu dois juste
[Musique]
oui c'est ma route
[Applaudissements]
oh c'est à propos de
[Musique]
celui-ci
c'est à propos  toi à l'une ou l'autre des basses
s'il est en retard
Oh non en
chantant fort
c'est tout
[Musique]
tu dois juste que
tu peux le faire